(high pitched music)
- [Ken] I always thought,
you know, a snow shoe
would really make a great cello.
A wooden chair back
makes a cool guitar body.
It turns out that one of my most playable
instruments is a golf club.
I'm seeing that transformative
quality in my head all the time.
What can I say, I'm attracted to trash.
I don't know why.
(pleasant music)
- [Narrator] Check out the
Jimi Hendrix of shovels.
- [Narrator] It's a guitar
made up of lots of junk.
- He even plays his zipper, from Brooklyn,
New York, please welcome Ken Butler.
(applause)
- My name is Ken Butler,
I'm an artist and musician
and known for building my
own experimental instruments.
Since 1978, I think I've
made around 400 instruments.
This whole thing started
for me when I was in
my basement in Portland,
Oregon and I saw a rusty old
beat up hatchet, put two strings
and two tuning pegs on it,
plugged it into my guitar
amp and was quite stunned
that it actually sounded
like a horrible violin.
(violin music)
The ax violin was the first time that
somebody said that's a cool idea.
If I go walking around the neighborhood,
everywhere you look, you see such
amazing conglomerations
of potential sculpture.
There's crutches, tennis
rackets, parts of furniture,
boom, I'm right there with that.
Ya know, when I build
stringed instruments,
really just need three things,
the head, the neck and the body.
A spoon has that parameter,
a key looks like a guitar.
It has the, you know, and then
there's the little body.
This is from a very inexpensive mandolin.
Of course some of the things become crazy
Baruch Asambleas of
multiple, multiple necks.
It's ridiculous but that's how it works.
My shovel guitar, I guess
it's a small snow shovel.
It's just a quirky object and it sounds
unbelievably beautiful, the
qualities and characters
that the golf club has is amazing.
(string music)
There's one that's made
from a beach paddle
that has a ukulele neck and a cane.
(string music)
Sometimes people think my
intention is humor, it's not.
I think it's surprising
to people that I can
generate genuine emotion
and meaning and real music
on something as ridiculous
as a hockey stick
or a tennis racket or a broom
or a shovel or a golf club.
At the real core of
what I'm doing, it's to
communicate to other people
that the things right around
them can be magical and
transformative and even spiritual.
Who knows, if I hadn't found
that ax, what would've happened.
(high pitched music)